is that something you would talk about
with anybody or not anybody but with
with yeah with anything
um well it is interesting thing about
how you know people often it's in
writing too you people often I read that
Edward R Murrow the newscaster told a
stranger on the plane next to him and he
had cancer and he'd never told any of
his family at that point you know what I
mean there's something about telling
strangers things that's interesting it's
like when you write I'll often write
things that
my 16 year old daughter asked me
something about my past and Sam said to
her if you want to know Dad you should
read his books
because
I'll write things and it's very true if
that goes to what we were just talking
about and also you know I'll be much
more forthcoming on the page than I will
be generally in life with people even
people I love and I always think and I'm
not the only one lots of people talk
about how that's the case and I think
that's really interesting how we do that
and why we do that and that's why they
say right what you know right yeah I
guess so and just write the truth right
because you write the truth right no I
remember writing the first book I didn't
I was right you know and it was a travel
Memoir but really it's about intimacy
and I remember writing a paragraph going
oh my God this could never be in the
book and I'm typing away and this could
never never there's no way I'm
embarrassed this is like way too
revealing yeah and then I finished and I
finish and I read it and I go well
that's there's no chapter without that
paragraph that's the whole thing and you
know because all you're trying to do is
you know they're just feelings
everybody's got them and you start with
writing you're just trying to create a
connection with the reader so that
they're nodding their head whether they
sit alone in their bed at night they
with you and they're nodding their head
and that's how I feel that's how I feel
and then you've then you've got
something yeah have you ever
like are you one of those I like I had
never heard my dad cry until he lost his
daughter my half-sister who passed away
a few years ago and talk about shell
shocked talk about
um and it was sort of expected
throughout the year she had the Trisomy
chromosomal thing going on for years and
she was she was always in the hospital I
mean she lived in the hospital
children's hospital and
you know he was dealing with this a lot
of time and then when she passed
I called him
and I I couldn't even understand him it
was like a different human being I've
never heard that kind of cry he was so
hurt and I just didn't know what even to
do I was emotional I was
I just said I love you I'm here for you
and it was
it was heartbreaking it was
heartbreaking it's not something I think
you want to see your father there's some
people like oh my Daddy's always crying
oh he's everything he watches this he
cries I think that's one of the greatest
things we can do for our kids is show
them our Frailty
you know what I mean we don't want to do
that as dads of course you're strong
with this or that when we got it sorted
out and you know but I think you know
there's a moment on the walk when we're
walking and I tripped and I fell and I
almost crashed into this thing that
would have really been a problem and
I hit hard and I normally jump bounce
right back up if I fall because I'm so
embarrassed that I just don't know I'm
fine fine you know but I didn't bounce
back up and I just felt and it's a much
lighter thing than what you're talking
about obviously but the metaphor of it's
the same is I I hit the ground and I
stayed there and my son was shocked at
this because I never I'm pretty agile on
that you know and so
and he helped me and I realized just let
him help you let him help you it's
important for him to see that part of me
you know what I mean and that's one of
the things I have to teach is that like
you know like my mom now is is not you
know she's getting to mention She's
suffering and like
you gotta go help them and that's
anyway and so that's part of life that's
part of the cycle of what happens and so
you know
so yeah for you to say that's important
thing for your dad for you to get to
experience that with your dad you know
what I mean that it's not just the other
way it's you know it's not it's a
two-way street which you know it takes
being in wanting that too